Hey Youtubers it's Charlie!
This is going to be my Gotham Episode 5 video.
Lot of comic book things happening.
You have the Court of Owls floating in the
background now we have the order of St. Dumas
which is where Azrael comes from he hasn't
come on the show yet they've actually cast
that actor to do that, and we get to see firefly
for the first time.
So just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet so I'm going to do go
through top five WTF moments and explain the
new characters and the storylines they're
introducing starting with number five the
police task force goes on the warpath so this
whole like this whole introduction scene with
the dues in their underpants might've seen
the little weird they're basically doing Tim
Burton's Batman the music that they use the
architecture the way they frame the scene
it's much more indicative of the style of
Tim Burton's Batman films if you watch the
Christopher Nolan Batman films all that was
filmed in Chicago so it looks a little bit
more normal so the reality of Gotham is just
heightened to a comic book level in a way
that a lot of other TV shows are visible raid
on the Penguin kind of leads into this theme
of friends being very very important like
the less you have the more important the ones
you do have become Penguin of course always
quick to grovel like Penguin versus the oh
this is going to be an interesting fight this
year wouldn't it be great if Penguin is the
want to ultimately take Theo down like you
you want Gordon to do it because he's one
of the protagonists the show but this is Gotham
it's all about the rise of the villains and
you have good villains and you have bad villains
the Penguin even though he's a big bad of
Gotham isn't going to be the biggest antagonist
the season that's Theo's character is just
like Capt.
cold on the flash Captain Cold, big big villain
that is going to be an antihero during legends
of tomorrow on the number for the Gordon versus
date night this reaction phase probably my
favorite reaction phase that he's ever done
on the show a mini a lot of mileage out of
this I love the idea of Riddler and Ms. Kringle
together doing crazy things but in this scene
there really just being like a disgustingly
happy couple I felt like that was a lot of
comedy be had and Ms. Kringle asking the Riddler
to go on couples dates so that you know that
there's like more witnesses a rat we should
be hanging around other people just in case
you get a little too crazy she might be aware
that he is going a little bit not that I think
she just senses the has really weird energy
about him and she is like slowly growing honor
you like a virus or fungus he just slowly
grows on you on the number three though Theo
versus Gordon Sophia is trying to get Gordon's
public endorsement because he's president
of the policeman's Union for the theater just
wants to legitimize himself in the eyes of
Gotham it takes the entire episode to get
there but the really interesting thing is
going on is the Gorin his totally drunk the
Kool-Aid at some point your maybe midseason
finale just like expect the road to get pulled
out from under Gordon like oh my God I made
a deal with the devil the interesting thing
is is their final senior the end of the episode
Theo is standing in front of this like this
gargoyles symbol up on the wall it combines
a lot of imagery about the history of Gotham
butyl like just like the Wayne family name
all over everything in the Dumas family is
well just looking really sinister like Theo
is the devil so Gordon here is kind of selling
his soul just a little bit on the number to
meet firefly brand-new comic book villain
on Gotham firefly in the comics is a completely
different character there's a C to mail versions
of firefly but all the tech like all the gear
is still the same so that's fairly true to
the comics with the exception of the jet pack
when firefly is appeared in the comics in
and in the cartoons he is a jet pack that
allows them to fly but for the most part like
of the fire gear like though the weaponry
is all the same as it is in the comics there
is like a whole lot of wire work on Gotham
yet and he just gives you Batman is like jumping
from rooftop to rooftop but I would expect
the show to do that at some point to especially
now that we had the order of St. Dumas who
is supposed to be just like a big group of
bad asses I was a if there's an area where
Gotham is been Lacking it's in its fight scenes
like arrow is a good example of a TV show
you know the people that don't have superpowers
but there's a lot of really bad as fight scenes
I feel like once Gotham I feel like was the
order of St. Dumas gets into Gotham will start
seeing a lot more bad ass fight scenes I don't
totally mind them changing the firefly character
from the comics a gets totally okay to give
the persona to a new character you can kinda
see that they're trying to set this actress
up to come back like they gave her this big
emotional arc in the episode showing how her
brothers are her adopted brothers have you
want to think about it were treating her like
she did so she's kind of a sympathetic villain
now Catwoman takes her under her Paul so just
expect this actors to come back like they
don't give an actor's this much story they
don't intend her to use her again so everybody
give firefly high 500 is going to be a lot
of fun on the show she's just another villain
like the Penguin somewhat sympathetic but
still doing evil things still a little bit
nutters in speaking of nutters one of my favorite
parts the episode though is part of this firefly
arc was when the idiots start the C4 down
his pants and ran I'm like that was the minute
you knew something was gonna happen to him
like a mystic this break of C4 that could
block a small building right in front of my
junk so that when the cops shoot me I'll just
go splat all over everything it was actually
quite a bit of comedy violence in this episode
people getting their digs blown off getting
their eyes gouged out getting their hands
chopped off you just let me know how you feel
about balance in the game of thrones level
violence when it's done for comedy like Gotham
did it this week that's when I feel like an
episode has done a really good job but that's
comedy done well when you feel bad about laughing
like who that's who I should laugh then finally
on my number one WTF moment the history of
Gotham explained so this is the show this
is actually really cool because of the show
deepening its mythology using the comics in
most of this is true like flows from quarter
bowels type stuff now this week's episode
only lightly invoked the quarter Val's it
was mostly about the origins of the order
of St. Dumas the first half of the season
isn't necessarily culminating to a quarter
Val storyline it's culminating towards and
as rel storyline order St. Dumas this big
invasion that they been teasing their kind
of like a religious order version of the league
of assassins but there are a couple historical
way that are mentioned in the episode the
one that is typically credited with building
a lot of the biggest structures in Gotham
is Solomon Wayne he was he was a judge one
of the early founders of the Greathouse Wayne
with the earliest Wayne to live in Gotham
was named Nathaniel Wayne and he was he was
like an immigrant that lived in Gotham when
it was just a colony if you want to read a
lot about the history of the Wayne family
in you've already read the quarter Val storyline
then read Batman after final crisis gets sent
back in time by Darkside Omega beams just
keeps jumping fords you keep seeing wanes
throughout history and now we know Theo's
family are the Dumas in their on this holy
crusade to redeem Gotham right the wrong that
was done to their family had just explained
as rel he is coming on the show they been
cast the actor who plays him but he's going
to be comparable to Bruce Wayne's age so he
won't be as rel yet I'm not expecting to see
the suit of sorrows but we might see some
references and stuff like that that that just
like some special armor that the order of
St. Dumas constructed it has some mystical
properties derive from the blood dead of a
bunch of crusaders but usually drives the
wearer mad so just because Gotham hasn't gotten
into magic or mysticism and lilies like the
way arrow has not expecting to see any kind
of magical artifacts you just let me know
that like what was your big WTF moments in
the episode was of the dude getting his Dick
blown off was it Butch getting his hand chopped
off or is it the tease of the order St. Dumas
writing in on Gotham just a beat the shit
out of everybody the whole episode was great
though I'd I feel like they're laying a lot
of seeds that will definitely pay off later
down the road hopefully firefly's character
will fall through the cracks a lot a lot of
time shows that have been cast can lose people
in the mix like by the time you get to the
end of the season it's like all we know we
meant to do something with this character
but we just we could find a place for them
again in speaking of finding people again
didn't you think it was funny how Catwoman
was like fish many could totally come back
I feel like that's the voice of the fandom
the people that like fish movie I was not
one of those people I was in a huge fan of
her character but she could totally come back
in some way if jaded Pinkett Smith wanted
to come back was can happen next is is since
it's Sunday him and to be doing game of thrones
The Walking Dead just like normal hopefully
both of those videos a post on time I'm still
in the middle of moving like I'm still recording
videos of my old apartment while I'm moving
into my new apartment to just be sure to follow
me on Facebook and twitter to find out when
videos are coming it's gonna be another week
or two before I'm finished moving and I'll
totally do a room tour video when it's all
done but while you wait for all the videos
to post you can click here for all my flash
and arrow videos and you can click here to
watch the Jessica Jones trailer again if you
haven't seen it yet, thank you so much for
watching.
everybody let's high five and I'll see you
guys tonight!